what i want to do in this video is try
to figure out what 35
plus 22 plus 10 plus 16
is equal to so pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
all right now let's work through this
together now as you will learn there's
many ways
to approach this but the way i'll think
about it is
by thinking about place value for
example
when we look at 35 we have three tens
and five ones three tens right over here
that's the same thing as 30.
so you could view 35 as 30
plus five and we could do the same thing
for 22.
22 is two-tenths which is 20
that's what that 2 tells us plus 2 ones
so 20 plus 2 and then we have 10
which is just 1 10 and no ones so
plus 10 and then 16 we could rewrite
that
as being the same thing as 110 so 10
plus six ones plus six ones
now why was this useful now i could take
all of the things
that are a certain number of tens so 30
20
10 and 10 and try to add those together
and then separately i will try to add
the five the two and the six
and when you see when i do it i think
it'll make a little bit of sense why
why it's useful so we have a 30
plus 20 plus 10
plus 10 plus that purple 10
plus that purple 10. so i've already
accounted for the 30 the 20
that 10 and that 10 and then i'll have
all of the things that were written in
the ones place before
so plus five ones so i got that taken
care of
plus two ones taken care of
plus six ones plus six ones
and now all of these we can think about
what is 30
plus 20 well 30 plus 20 is going to be
50 and then 50 plus 10 is 60
and then 60 plus 10 is 70. so that's all
going to be 70.
another way to think about it is we have
3 tens plus 2 tens plus 110 plus 110
3 plus 2 plus 1 plus one is seven so we
have
seven tens and you actually saw that up
here as well
three tens plus two tens plus one
ten plus one ten that's going to give us
seven tens and then we can add this
other part where we see 5
plus 2 is 7 plus 6
is 13. so it's 70
plus 13. now what is 70 plus 13
well i could rewrite 13 i could do
something similar as
10 plus 3 and that makes it a little bit
more obvious
we can see that that's the same thing as
70 plus 10
which is 80 plus three
which is the same thing as eight tens
and three ones
which is equal to eighty
three and we're done